France Talbot et Jean-Marc Dumet sont
des randonneurs aguerris
ils observent beaucoup de nouveaux
amateurs de plein air souvent on envoie
vraiment des petites espadrilles depuis
la pandémie plus de gens qui savent pas
comment se préparer mais une mauvaise
préparation peut entraîner de mauvaises
surprises même chez les plus
expérimentés en 2020 on est parti quatre
personnes au mont gros avec ma blonde
puis deux amis que on les initier un
petit peu à leur première grosse
expédition la quatrième journée il s'est
mis à avoir un blizzard puis il y a eu
20 cm de neige durant la journée nos
deux amis leur bottes étaient pas
adéquates pour le climat après 14 heures
d'attente ils ont été secourus par
l'armée canadienne
et même sur les sentiers bien balisés
donc c'est au niveau de la planification
de leur visite que qui auraient de
l'amélioration à faire garder les cartes
avant de venir et on peut planifier leur
itinéraire des fois ils peuvent arriver
mal chaud c'est il arrive avec pas assez
d'eau les premiers répondants
plus d'incidents plus de sortie
c'est sorti implique beaucoup de
ressources 9 pompiers sont nécessaires
pour transporter ce panier en montagne
avec un ascension d'environ 600 mètres
ça peut nous prendre jusqu'à deux heures
deux heures et demie on a déjà vu
jusqu'à trois heures juste pour
atteindre la victime
à l'échelle de la province les appels à
la sûreté du Québec pour les opérations
de recherche sauvetage ont aussi
augmenté
361 appels en 2021 une hausse de 40% par
rapport à 2018
les opérations de sauvetage restent tout
de même minimes sur le total de
randonneurs chaque année
la randonnée demeure une activité sur et
accessible il suffit de bien s'équiper
ici marisabelle Rochon Radio-Canada
Montréal